pierre frédéric billets mer et l'air de
dreux président du conseil de
surveillance du centre hospitalier de
dreux bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
alors vous faites partie des signataires
de cette tribune qu est ce que vous
reprochez à ce projet bonsoir oui
différents reproche le premier temps que
nous sommes dans un contexte un peu
particulier en provence avec eux depuis
18 mois la qu'ovide frappe le monde
hospitalier
et si oui on a l'impression quand même
qu'on remet en cause la loi busin et qui
a été votée à deux ans sur les plates
formes de téléphone et centrale d'appels
pour toutes les questions de santé et de
secours c'est bien différencier et
convient encore percuté le monde
hospitalier avec une réforme qui n'a pas
été concerté avec le monde hospitalier
et qui vient d'être mis en place comme
un cheveu sur la soupe alors que le
contexte est ultra sensible dans tous
les hôpitaux de france et donc voilà il
faut être raisonnable il faut prendre le
temps des choses la loi le projet de loi
matras on peut en discuter il ya des
choses qui sont intéressantes mais en
tout cas sur la plateforme unique et le
numéro unique
je pense et avec mes collègues nous
pensons que c'est une bêtise qui ne
rendra pas un service meilleur à nos
concitoyens
pourtant on entend quand même des
arguments de bon sens un souvent les
pompiers d'ailleurs qui sont plutôt pour
cette initiative explique souvent c'est
que je piste pour les administrés qui se
perdent 1 puis peu dans tous les numéros
sera pas une manière justement de
centraliser et quitte être aiguille
correctement après alors tout à fait si
vous voulez l'idée la loi busin été
atteinte et la fiancée de 10 ans faisons
deux métiers différents
donc vous avez les services de secours
qu'on appelle les sapeurs pompiers
notamment et les services de santé
c'est ce qu'on appelle le samu mais qui
peut regrouper d'autres choses dont on
peut avoir le 115 pour les personnes
sans domicile fixe le françaises de
110,9 qui peuvent regrouper toutes les
questions de santé
c'est assez intéressant et les services
de secours simplement c'est que quelques
chiffres pour comprendre la situation
aujourd'hui nous avons 29 millions
d'appels par an au service des familles
22 millions pour les sapeurs pompiers
sur ces 29 millions
d'appel que le samu reçoit partout en
france la moitié des appels sont traités
directement au téléphone par simple
conseil avec des agents régulateur avec
des médecins coordinateurs pour que les
gens aient un bon conseil et soient bien
dirigées les sapeurs pompiers font un
métier de secours et donc ont le réflexe
plus souvent de faire déplacer les
véhicules et du personnel sur place pour
prendre en charge les personnes parfois
assez utile et parfois c'est pas utile
bon c'est à dire que si on devait avoir
un numéro de téléphone unique
malheureusement on viendrait engorgé
parfois sans raison les services
d'urgence qui font extrêmement tendues
depuis des années est d'autant plus
depuis un an et demi on a vu également
dans le sujet que beaucoup de pays il
utilise notamment par exemple la
belgique tout simplement il ya le canada
les pays bas et que ça se passe plutôt
bien ça veut dire quoi que nos systèmes
sont pas vraiment comparables alors déjà
il faut comprendre que les services de
secours c'est de me faire l'intérieur
des services de santé fait les
ministères d'affronter alors sortons un
peu de ce fantasme du numéro du 112
il utilisait par quelques pays en europe
c'est frêche mais c'est pas la majorité
et puis si vous voulez faut bien
comprendre que une seule plate forme de
téléphone c'est aussi prendre un risque
en cas de panne d'attac de virus d'
attaques de hackers que cette plate
forme pendant plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs jours ne puissent plus
fonctionner savez dans l'armée on dit en
tout cas c'est simple on dit deux c1 et
1 0 c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on arrive
à sécuriser les appels avec deux
plateformes bien distincts qui le cas
échéant quand il ya un problème puisse
prendre le relais du premier kit en
panne et ça c'est une vraie sécurité
pour nos concitoyens pour les kabyles de
secours les services de santé
est-ce qu'ils aient enfin un avantage
économique à n'avoir qu'un seul numéro
dans un pays
malheureusement qui a bien besoin et
s'estimant de d'économie semble-t-il
alors vous savez les grandes réformes
imaginez à paris quand les voies sion
terrain c'est souvent catastrophiques
vous verrez que si malheureusement cette
réforme va se mettre en place dans
quelques mois on créera des pauses pour
la coordination la coopération et au
final ça coûtera plus cher
vous savez il ya il ya une mouvance
comme pas en ce moment on supprime
le corps préfectoral pour des raisons
qu'on ne comprend pas bien les réformes
de grandes institutions qu'on regroupe
et après ça pour ça que ça fonctionne
plus on les sépare
c'est des mouvements sans cesse de
d'état moi je suis très prudent moi je
fais confiance aux acteurs locaux
je fais confiance aux hospitaliers qui
ont prouvé durant ce qu vide et encore
du site sienne que sont des gens sérieux
il faut la faire confiance savez les
sapeurs pompiers ils ont besoin d'une
chose ils ont besoin d'une
reconnaissance donc sans financière et
de moyens et des hospitaliers c'est
pareil de la reconnaissance les cds
travailler les faits les tranquilles et
surtout monsieur monsieur le ministre
écoutez vos hospitalier qui connaissent
très bien terrain etc ont besoin
d'écouté et d'appui une enquête complète
forme
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec mon
pierre frédéric billets pour évoquer ce
sujet mais leur l air de dreux